happy Thursday reject nation all-female
reboot oceans 8 Danny ocean sister
played by Sanja block and a whole bunch
of other women are in this and hey
speaking of women patron the day shout
out for a Delia Chamberland hey cuz
you're late
no ocean convicted felon her brother
Danny knows more convicted felon she was
present on the night of the incident the
incident in mind yes nice
[Music]
sixteen point five million dollars in
each of your bank accounts five weeks
your mouth
[Music]
how long did it take you to figure all
this out five years eight months and 12
days why do you need to do this
you still win the love of her ex-husband
[Music]
[Music]
dear God that was exact you with this
[Music]
we will not be
[Music]
[Laughter]
well that looks fun
look at it looks like delightful it
looks enjoyable I was watching trim I'm
like you know it's actually smart that
they cut it down from 11 or 12 or 13
people to just eight yeah because it's
more manageable and then when I look
back at oceans law what I'm like yeah I
remember it was it was some of those
people do I gotta forget other people's
eight makes it easier to remember the
whole ensemble and know the purpose each
one of them serve while it does have
that hang out vibe that we expect from
the oceans movies when you get like a
bunch of celebrities together they also
still feel like they're playing
characters I appreciate that this is
real like all these hot actresses showed
up and are cashing in and check you know
yeah and it also feels right in line
with the oceans tone that you know yeah
I'm just kind of like why didn't Steven
Soderbergh just direct this if Gary
Rob's gonna shoot this exactly like a
Steven Soderbergh this entire thing
harkens back exactly to the first
Ocean's eleven the first bullets been
released her in prison which is just
like Danny ocean and now she has it so
glad she's had this home for all these
years
she has some real personal motivation
that we don't quite know yet
that's why she's gonna get her
ex-husband so it's gonna have just like
Danny ocean it's obviously the rusty yes
she's very much the rails like you just
look like you're chilling out and having
a great time yeah and at least they're
not trying to do some like remake this
yeah she's Danny ocean sister they're
making that evident all they gotta do is
make a groovy heist movie with a certain
amount of style and a good ensemble and
there you go you got notions movie yeah
and they're robbing the Met you know
that's a pretty cool you know
high-profile place you know with eight
when they started to kind of break down
the plan I was like oh yeah it does seem
really challenging and I'm excited to
see how they're able to pull it off and
I like how they don't like to give away
any of the actual heist and the trailer
which I thought was neat to do I feel
like some people would be upset by just
kind of how rehash it can sort of feel
just would like women in the roles but
it's an oceans movie I feel like the
expectation for oceans movie with
anybody in it it's just to replicate
this kind of a tone and have a cool
point is really matter
hey patron the day shout out for a Delia
Chamberlain I know right now where you
live you can feel kind of bored and that
you feel like you can do more
interesting things I think you got to
find yourself a group of female thieves
to join better than a book clubs better
than a book club especially cuz I know
you can be really introverted too this
is your chance to get out there and
socialize go find some Facebook groups
of people who are putting together some
heists is you'd be the perfect candidate
man I could see you planning introverts
are the best when it comes to pulling
off bravery oh down surprising you with
the amount of thought you've put into a
task of some kind
Adelia become a thief because you're a
hot woman and hot woman thieves easier
you know yeah you can own the hearts of
many in men and you know a lot of
valuable property I'm sure or money
whatever you want to steal men are more
important guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell so the subscribe but it means
something check us on patreon hold like
TV show reactions weekly q and A's would
love to have you become a patron
objected a